I'm so excited for you guys because you
guys just create okay hits after hits
hits that's true ya know if that was
true of them we're definitely not sick
of it definitely on a high right now
yeah thank you
this year how would you explain it in
terms of the positivity that's going
through your day um well I think like
you know we've had a lot of like really
exciting things happen to us since day
one and but like this year like mentally
I think we've like become the strongest
that we've ever been and I think we've
been like closer friends this year and
more like being able to be much more
honest and open and communicative with
each other like I feel like in the past
like just getting to know someone like
it's a very stressful situation there's
a lot of a stressful situations you're
faced with and like we also like when we
kind of took off in people like what we
looked like and what we were called and
like whatever it was this joy music and
everyone had an opinion that was a
really like hard thing to do it for a
while and this year we like got over it
and now we're like confidently ourselves
which is probably my favorite thing
that's happened this year what was the
train point for you weekend in Ibiza no
I was kidding but that did no I think
you know figuring out a way to put our
feelings into our music and not just in
like then we always kind of poke fun at
like our generation and our music and
kind of write about the ridiculous
things that we do the way we relate to
each other romance
social media but I've seen Romantic era
like right now oh yeah yeah yeah and a
good in a good way good but I think like
you know we our album right now it's
called sick boy and we've been adding
songs to it all year which has been
really fun but we figured out a way to
talk about kind of the darker feelings
that we have in like a in a way to get
them out there but not to be like you
know poor us I mean that's an important
thing for artists right for you you have
the ability to write songs or write
about your emotions and the darkness and
all of all of that people have that
conversation how has the reaction been
for you from your friend terrible no no
I'm kidding
they're they've been really receptive I
mean we have an amazing group of fans
internationally that seem to always ride
with us no matter what we do and we
actually like listen to their input a
lot about the things they say in regards
to our music and what they're wanting
and what they liked or disliked but in
the day I think you know they want us to
be ourselves and and that's what we're
best at doing so you know we're grateful
for that and it makes the whole process
really fun for us and Emily Warren she's
very happy yeah yeah she's the homie no
how would you explain her talent um
she's like the best listener ever and
she'll get you she makes you feel
comfortable arias too and she just hears
everyone out she really like she's like
a therapist like she'll listen to what
you're going through and then like press
on something that sounds interesting and
then you'll go deeper in that and you
know not only do you get a song but you
figure out some life stuff too at the
same time when we're out there what has
she been pressing on recently it's been
tough we were in a really big place yeah
so now we have to talk about her she has
some drama final yeah we're pressing her
yeah but she's taught us how to do it
yeah and Kelsea Ballerini on you she
want to work with you guys we have this
song of but a country singer is it
everything you go yeah and more I mean
she's the coolest most like charming
girl on the planet she's got an
incredible voice it makes the project
really fun when you have when you're
able to work with someone like that and
and we've obviously done some pretty
incredible things like the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show Monday Night
Football New Year's Eve so all these
amazing things that we kind of we have
this funny text chain wherever like we
talk you know like it infrequently but
like we catch up and it's like the last
few texts are like so we're doing a
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show and it's
like yay and then no response and then
like the next things like we're playing
Monday Night Football and it's like oh
man yeah and it's like this crazy you
know list of things that were going
through together and I think she's just
getting started I think she's gonna have
like a really really
really massive year and yeah we're lucky
that were you know part of that are
those surreal moments for you to
Victoria's Secret and doing a football
game is that just you're up there
thinking wow yeah totally
we we started playing as a band like two
years ago which will you'll see tonight
we explain to our first tour as a band
here it's a venue and you know that's
been it took a while to really like be
confident with that show but it is so
much fun and like now that like we're
confident about doing that stuff being
able to do it on Monday Night Football
the Victoria Secret Fashion Show it's
kind of like is so fun and you have
shows in Vegas as well oh yeah we got
fifty shows a year and at the weigh-in
that excess in Vegas for the next three
years we're finishing at the end of this
year we'll have three more years that's
great it's a lot but it's so much fun
and they take such good care of us and
our friends so yeah come through if
you're in Vegas there's no better time
than well that's what's the thing for me
I'm a bed by 10 o'clock I will then wake
up again at 1:00 yeah about how about
you get up early the video would tell
see Ballerini there's drag racing
involved with it did you guys actually
do any of it yeah yeah yeah yeah and you
see me hit that jump obviously double
backflip on motorbikes and we look like
bikers yeah end of the year Christmas is
around the corner
yeah are you excited about taking the
holidays with the families yeah so
excited I mean this weave shows
basically through they like to 12 and
then after that we're probably still
working the studio and stuff but yeah
we're both big family guys and that's
like a rare time of year where everyone
leaves us alone you know and you kind of
just get to enjoy that moment and we're
gonna you know have a great time just
chillin and hanging
the only time of year that you can feel
like no one else is doing anything to so
you don't feel guilty about not doing
anything I mean yeah give me take a day
off you're like damn the rest of worlds
like doing that thing today
you know so do you want anything for
presents
do you would like about I've been told
I'm a tough person to get gifts for her
so I kind of just get myself this stuff
I want what do you what do you want this
here I'm more of like like I want a
laser tag set yeah okay so I bought this
house that is like this and has like an
open space in the middle and there's all
windows so you can run through the house
and snipe people through the windows and
I found these like laser tag guns that
are like four hundred dollars apiece and
they're like they like shake and make
crazy noises and they have long range
you can like pinpoint things am I in my
house yeah that's what I want that's a
Friday night with more practical yeah
yeah I want a laser tag set
whoever's watching yeah that's what I
want it makes noise and stuff and
finally what is your favorite Christmas
song I carry all I want for Christmas
everyone say that that's a good one Jan
yeah all right elbow it's good right
what wait no Christmas album really can
you do one really do or what it sound
like not the vibe I feel like not the
body come on we're moving like uplifting
like oh yeah yeah we can do it huh do we
have this thing about Santa they all
sing about Santa they don't you could
you just join the ball okay see the ball
keep the Bell well do we happen to exist
can we write our own is that okay
all right oh yeah you heard person it's
called snowballs thank you
Thanks ladies are talking about to look
into them oh yeah